hello and welcome to zero playing crow
moss with a black and it's a we try this
g6 variation kind of interesting I thing
for for a change yeah one players often
don't know this line this in Bishop g5
is actually something that i don't like
very much but i can also take with the
night now i think this is the most
common way of playing it uh-huh just
castles I don't know that one
interesting usually why takes on c6 and
then only for wow ok and probably nine
f6 I mean that looks like the most
natural move
uh-huh nobody takes it interesting we
should g four Izzy five so I cannot do
this can i play this someone my active
way
what irritates me is possible gift for a
wider play you five and then 94 somewhat
irritating oh that's interesting more
tries to I mean I cannot go 97's a thing
but I can class along this is something
that I did not I did not didn't think
will be possible probably in this game
anymore let's castle mall I think I'm
probably not really thought I'm
threatening and so in some way nights
you for threatening is really wrong it's
not a not something that would scam wyd
a lot okay so what's the deal step two
is six Nyjah for Queen f4 hmm
so that doesn't really does that doesn't
really do much look T 2 looks like a
move but then 95 is a net is an issue
very serious issue I can play 97 or
something like that but that's still
Queen f4 okay let's step out of this
diagonal this ending isn't a big issue I
think because I get to the second ring
Jack and this will be 6 as well and 94
probably whom that isn't that great oak
detours rook rook f2 moon and okay
okay so i can do this now getting rid of
my double pawn it shouldn't be too bad
if five however this is a move that
could be irritating nope okay i'm just
taking cheque book c6 next check so 95
rookie three okay okay now King III the
normal looking move doesn't work because
of 95 and I have to check on the second
rank in case of 95 so let's see what he
does now
not so easy to play for him this one
okay I can definitely do this 195 is
this the thing or up to 5 system ok ok
it still looks good
hello kim taek's here okay five King the
Seven Kingdoms square for the ruckus
this is a bit of an annoyance ready okay
so
hmm yeah it's not ideal absolutely not
preparing since 6am time warning
slightly behind on the clock the set
some cause for concern you
not kill you will see 5 it was an
impossible earlier
I can do this g3 here Jack and 10 9 p-6
made it's the idea which you want
jackals and prevent I know it's got
Nancy for coming oh that's it was a
stupid play now that was still very
stupid very stupid where did you check
check does an ending that was just
slightly better for black and I managed
to lose it ah that's terrible black
purse I i I'll super stupid him I mean
hear your black is to slightly better in
this ending and then managed to lose
that very bad they are probably being
too ambitious or so because it is still
probably equal yeah this is the thing
check check a 96 is just totally stupid
that's this is still carrier thing like
this is what the engine is giving and
check it should probably be a draw he's
getting this yeah but I thought I'm just
better you why am I not been my pawns
look more dangerous in terms of getting
a passer now maybe it is just to the
draw
yeah I'd what ah the old castle actually
blundered 95mm amelie I saw that this
move was somewhat possible that i didn't
see that I'm just losing a piece him I
cannot take with the rookie so this is
probably yeah so I deserve blocks and
after i blundered the penis and check
check my Knight f3 is clearly better ah
very very bad game he could have one
after blunder and I had chances to win
this ending instead am I just lose it ok
anyway whoa thanks for watching